I want to talk a little bit about this
idea of asking questions now we've
talked before
about how I'm just asking questions is
sometimes used to create cover for bad
faith questions destructive questions
corrosive questions push questions like
for example listen I'm just asking
questions if Democrats continue their
communist murder campaign of Republicans
would you still vote for them
guys I'm just asking questions you're
not going to tell me questions are bad
are you we've seen it used in that way
but I want to mention something else
about question and questions and it
relates to our friend Fox News
propagandist Tucker Carlson asking
questions in and of itself
isn't virtuous
isn't virtuous asking obviously stupid
ridiculous questions meant merely to
fire up low information voters isn't
something we should celebrate but Tucker
is increasingly using this meme
questions are we no longer allowed to
ask questions in the United States
as he likes to laugh if
everybody is free to ask questions about
it yeah and demand real answers if
you're
coming up with some sort of crazy theory
about what happened to Nancy Pelosi's
house last Friday instead of yelling at
you or calling you names or telling you
you're a conspiracy not your Alex Jones
Just Produce the police body cam why is
that so hard if you think something
weird was going on in January 6th okay
it's not your fault maybe it's the fault
of the people who are hiding thousands
of hours of video or maybe the fault of
the people telling you something weird
went on when uh okay and events from
January 6th why haven't they released
that the onus is on them not the rest of
us we're not the crazy people you're the
Liars okay so a couple different things
there Tucker fundamentally
misunderstands burden of proof If you
are going to make a claim like for
example a claim that's been made many
times there was fraud in multiple States
organized by different people in each
state significant enough that the true
winner if it represented the will of the
voters would have been Trump instead of
Biden
it's up to you
if you believe that instead of a of an
obviously politically motivated
right-wing attack on the Pelosi
household in San Francisco last week
what took place was
a lover's quarrel between Paul Pelosi
and his gay prostitute who was already
inside the house at the time of the
altercation you need to produce that
evidence you need to produce that
evidence but let's put a side burden of
proof
we shouldn't fall for the Absurd notion
that bad faith absurd questions should
be celebrated because in a vacuum asking
questions is a good thing
I think we're dealing mostly with adults
at least legally to a three-year-old you
might want to encourage curiosity and
all that and you say there's never a
stupid question always I want to hear
every single one of your questions oh
it's a beautiful thing
to a six-year-old when they ask a silly
question you might say that's such a
silly question let me tell you why to a
10 year old you might say hey you know
what let's focus our questions uh uh to
build on what we already know you know
that there's some questions that are
useful and some questions that are just
nonsense but to adults you would say cut
the stupid questions you imbeciles it is
neither good nor righteous to make up
so-called evidence out of the blue claim
that now it is the default official
story we should believe and then ask
other people to disprove your crazy
ideas the immediate assumption should be
why is that the question at this point
in time where is the burden of proof
does the evidence actually fit that
being the question and being put in the
position all the time by these folks to
prove negatives the way they love to do
it's not virtuous it's not to be admired
it's simply nonsense and so let's not
fall for there's no such thing as stupid
or silly questions there are what you
say to a kid about questions is
different than what you might say to
Tucker Carlson or to these Maga people
keep it in mind if you have a friend or
loved one who is passionate about the
environment here is a perfect holiday
gift our sponsor established titles is a
project that lets you ceremonially
purchase as little as one square foot of
dedicated land in edelston Scotland so
that you can call yourself a lord or a
lady like the historic Scottish
tradition some people even change their
plane tickets or credit cards to include
Lord or lady your title pack comes with
an official certificate you can see
exactly where your plot of land is
located it makes a perfect last minute
gift but most importantly established
titles plants one free tree for every
plot of land sold established titles
does really good work all over the world
with reforestation organizations like
one tree planted and trees for the
future so you'll have a great laugh
whether you're Scottish or not I'm not
but you're giving the gift of
reforestation to fight climate change if
you use my link you'll get 10 off and
your plot of land will be right next to
mine you can see it on a map go to
establishtitles.com Pacman and use the
code Pacman for an extra 10 off on top
of their Black Friday deal the link is
down below